salut romain ça charbon dit tu es ok
d'accord tu vas faire ça toute la
journée on fait mach est pas là pour
faire comparaître ou de balle bon ok ok
tu m'a cassé
[Musique]
l'épais c'est quand même quelque chose
d'un peu particulier d'abord parce que
comme le caca c'est le point commun
entre absolument tous les êtres humains
sans distinction d'âge de genre de
religion d'orientation sexuelle d'ethnie
etc
l'épais c'est ce qui nous unit toutes et
tous pourtant c'est comme le cac a
toujours un sens que c'est pas un truc
comme les autres le sont c'est ça le
vois comme ça toute la vidéo vraiment
ceci dit c'est exactement ça que je
parle
l'épaisse a déclenché un mélange de
fascination répulsion ça fait rire ça
dégoûte
ça prend toujours quelque chose de fort
et pourtant c'est le truc le plus banal
qui soit on fait ça tous les jours et
même plusieurs fois par jour je veux
dire ça fait rire personne quand on
respire par exemple ça dégoûte personnes
quand on respire non plus non ça dépend
de qui respire et de la distance de
votre nez à laquelle des respirateurs
mais bon bref je vais vous présenter
quelques infos et quelques fun fact sur
les plaies et on va commencer tout de
suite par les présentations
c'est quoi un fait en paix ces composés
de l'air qu'on avale en mangeant mais
aussi de différents gaz produit par les
innombrables bactéries qu'on a tout le
long de l'intestin et qui nous aident à
dégrader les animaux donc nos pères et
nos peines mais c'est aussi d'épais de
bactéries pourquoi ça sent mauvais
là ça sent mauvais parce que les paies
de bactéries ça sent mauvais c'est un
peu le serpent qui se mord la queue
bon pour être un peu plus précise qui
sent mauvais c'est le sulfure
d'hydrogène qu'elle rejette c'est une
substance à base de soufre irna dans les
boules puantes par exemple dans nos
plaies y en a moins d'un pour cent mais
on le sent bien
le reste de l'honneur ben ça dépend de
ce qu'on a allongé c'est l'odeur des
aliments qu'on a digéré
objectivement ça sent pas mauvais ça
pourrait même sentir bon s'ils savaient
pas voyager tout ce temps avec du cac a
comme voisin et si ça se faisait papeete
dessus par des bactéries
évidemment c'est variable d'un individu
à l'autre ça dépend de ce que vous
mangez de votre tolérance digestive et
de votre flore intestinale c'est à dire
de votre petit élevage de bactéries
personnel parce qu'on n'a pas tous les
mêmes
en même quantité pourquoi ça fait du
bruit
bon alors déjà oui d'accord ça fait pas
toujours du bruit même ne jouais pas sur
les mots elle m'a c'est vrai ça fait
plus ou moins de bruit en fonction de la
quantité de gaz qu'on a stocké dans le
rectum avant de leur rendre leur liberté
et donc en fonction de la pression cette
pression en sortant et fait vibrer la
paroi de l'intestin au niveau de l'anus
et les sphincters qui font la sécu pour
empêcher des trucs de sortir au mauvais
moment et quand ça vibre ça fait du
bruit fait du bruit s'il vous plaît tout
le monde fait environ quatorze fois par
jour voilà donc premières infos je les
ai déjà dit mais j'insiste tout le monde
pète comme ça les choses sont claires
vous pouvez arrêter de faire son nom est
donc deuxième à faut un être humain
équipé d'un anus traditionnelle et d'une
fonction intestinale normale évacuent en
moyenne 14 gaz par 24 heures ça situe
entre une dizaine de fois et 25 fois
pour ceux qui font de la compet mais
elle fait du coup sachez le si vous vous
retenez toute la journée vous allez tout
lâcher la nuit pendant votre sommeil
à vous de voir si vous préférez vous
fâcher avec vos collègues de bureau ou
avec la personne qui partage votre
couche votre lit alors bien sûr il y
aurait la solution dans lâché 14 le
matin genre sous la douche comme ça
c'est fait après on en parle plus de la
journée désolé non c'est pas comme ça
que ça se passe
en plus ce péter sous la douche mais bon
ça on va y revenir se retenir c'est une
mauvaise idée
oui parce que bien sûr il ya aussi la
solution de se retenir mais il faut
savoir que retenir ces gaz ça a le même
effet que se retenir d'uriner ou de
déféquer c'est un mot en l'occurrence le
gaz en s'accumulant
ce temps la paroi de l'intestin et à
force ça l'avenir mais pour mieux
comprendre je vous propose de procéder à
une petite reconstitution romain
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on a vu qu'on aime étaient en moyenne 14
flatulences par 24 heures à raison de 15
à 100 voire 500 millilitres de gaz à
chaque paie on estime donc qu on rejette
entre 500 millilitres et 2 litres de gas
intestinale par 24 heures en gros pour
certains c'est une pinte de prout par
jour pour d'autres apparemment c'est la
paire la pire je vais arrêter de relever
parce que ça vous encourageant fait en
tout cas à terme se retenir ça peut
provoquer des douleurs et des problèmes
de constipation donc péter non pas toi
ta main voilà ceci étant dit je vous
propose de continuer avec quelques
informations amusantes ou insolites
aussi appelé syfy
certains animaux de péta et oui il ya
des animaux qui n'ont pas de gaz
intestinaux parce qu'ils n'ont pas le
même système digestif que nous et
notamment parce qu'ils n'ont pas notre
microbiote intestinal
c'est à dire toutes ces petites
bactéries qu'on a dans les boyaux et qui
nous aident à digérer
si on en croit denis caruso et dany
rabat y'at-il les auteurs du guide
ultime de la flatulence animale les
oiseaux ne pète pas par exemple moi je
trouve ça triste voilà pourtant ils ont
l'air contents ils sont tout le temps
peut-être pour meubler le silence
justement je sais pas les araignées peut
être pas non plus les poissons rouges et
les paresseux pareil et puis alors aussi
donc méfiez vous de ce que vous voyez
sur internet les enfants
pourquoi les paies s'enflamme un ps est
un cocktail d'au moins 5 gaz différents
dons de l'hydrogène et du méthane qui
sont tous les deux des gaz inflammables
donc au contact d'une flamme
après bon c'est marrant si justement
mais collé une flamme à côté de sa venue
que annales ça reste pas la meilleure
idée du monde
d'ailleurs c'est pas le seul danger on
peut provoquer un incendie avec un fait
c'est arrivé à une femme d'une trentaine
d'années à tokyo qui subissait une
intervention au laser au niveau du col
de l'utérus
la patiente a expulsé un gaz intestinale
qui s'est enflammé au contact du
faisceau laser et qui a mis le feu au
chant chirurgicale c'est à dire aux
draps stérile que le chirurgien temps
avant de pratiquer l'intervention true
story alors en plus c'est très peu drôle
parce que la patiente a été sévèrement
brûlé
donc il faut le savoir pay plus là vers
le paient le plus long du monde a duré
près de trois minutes
le paient le plus long de l'histoire
serait locke du londonien bernard
clemens et il a duré deux minutes 42 oui
alors commencez pas à me dire oui moi
une fois j'ai pété pendant trois heures
et demie c'était un mariage et je
m'ennuyais
santé - ça compte pas ceci dit le record
de bernard clemens il n'a pas non plus
été homologué dans le guiness de cas en
deux minutes 42 c'est quand même très
long pour vous faire une petite idée
c'est comme si vous étiez sans vous
arrêter pendant toute la durée de la
chanson
peu m'importe de jul et c'est marrant
parce que moi c'est vraiment les faits
pourquoi les fesses en plus mauvais sous
la douche
je vous avais dit qu'on n'y reviendrai
l'épais sentent plus mauvais sous la
douche parce que c'est un endroit qui
réunit trois conditions qui favorisent
grandement la perception des odeurs la
chaleur d'abord qui favorise la
diffusion des molécules odorantes qui
composent les odeurs la vapeur d'eau
ensuite qui se lit très facilement à ces
mêmes composants et qui les transportent
jusqu'à nos récepteurs olfactifs et puis
le confinement qui fait que tout ça ça
circule en vase clos
on peut péter par l'urètre alors oui
déjà l'urètre c'est le trou du pipi donc
je suis effectivement en train de vous
dire qu'on peut l'uriné des paies à cet
instant précis vous êtes peut-être tenté
d'en faire votre parti trick mais
attendait de savoir comment ça marche
quand on peut évacuer les gaz
intestinaux par l'urètre
quand on en a dans la vessie et on en a
dans la vessie quand elle communique
avec les intestins alors salué sa garde
évidemment vous l'avez compris c'est pas
normal
donc c'est pas bon signe ça peut arriver
dans certains cas de cancers de maladies
inflammatoires ou ça peut être la
complication d'une intervention
chirurgicale par exemple et donc dans
ces cas là des gaz peuvent se retrouver
dans les urines et ça s'appelle une ope
ne maturi pneuma le souffle sûrs au
curry vous voyez on peut péter à table
j'avoue je suis là il est un peu
protégés bien cherché évidemment
techniquement on peut péter à table mais
les conventions sociales tout ça
pourtant on raconte que l'empereur
romain claude a émis un édit autorisant
les convives à péter pendant les
banquets pour leur éviter des douleurs
et des vallonnements alors bon je pense
que la loi ne s'applique plus
aujourd'hui mais vous faites comme vous
voulez à quelle vitesse 20 après à vous
voulez savoir comment on peut franchir
le mur du fion en matière de paie la
vitesse moyenne la plus fréquemment
cités c'est 11 kilomètres heure mais
j'ai rien trouvé qu'il était extra
scientifiquement donc on va dire on sait
pas trop où ça dépend
impey peut vous faire gagner un repas
et oui dans certains cas un pet peut
vous faire gagner un repas un de vos
paix à vous faux pas ont amené dans un
bocal alors une idée
non non c'est pas une monnaie d'échangé
dans une société secrète c'est une
pratique qui a cours à l'hôpital
alors il ya différents protocoles selon
les endroits mais ce qui peut arriver
c'est la chose suivante après une
anesthésie générale et une opération sur
le tube digestif vos intestins il met un
petit peu de temps à se remettre au
boulot et parfois on ne vous donne pas
un vrai repas temps qui s'y sont pas
vraiment recoller dans ces cas-là on
guette le retour de votre transit
intestinal
avant de vous apporter un de ces
délicieux plateau dont le people a le
secret et le premier signe du retour de
votre transit intestinal c'est un fait
la théorie c'est important mais si ça se
traduit pas en concret en quelque chose
qui peut vraiment améliorer votre
quotidien
c'est un peu triste alors je vous
propose de terminer sur deux tuto très
concret
comment péter sur comment vous avez
peut-être vu mon plus tôt pour apprendre
à roter sur commande que j'avais réalisé
avec une orthophoniste
bon je vous cache pas que là les
professionnels de santé se sont pas
bousculés vraiment pour le tuto
d'aujourd'hui en revanche il ya
plusieurs pétomane qui ont déjà livré
leurs petits secrets alors l'erreur ce
serait de penser qu'il faut manger des
aliments qui donne un maximum de gaz
pour en avoir toujours un prêt déjà ce
serait pas très confortable et pour des
professionnels ça peut s'apparenter à du
dopage
en vérité tout se passe par voie basse
la subtilité de l'exercice ça consiste à
faire rentrer de l'air ambiant dans
votre ex homme puis de l'expulser pour
obtenir la vibration tant convoité pour
ce faire il semble qu'ils aient
plusieurs techniques certains
recommandent la position allongée sur le
dos jambes relevé d'autres la position
accroupie et d'autres encore la posture
assise jambes écartées mais le truc qui
fait l'unanimité c'est qu'il faut être
détendu du sphincter pour laisser l'air
rentrée après il ya des petites
techniques perso pour faire appel d'air
vous laisse trouver la vôtre mais
apparemment monsieur méthane
le célèbre monsieur métal lui ils tous
avec un évidement je vous mets le lien
vers la vidéo en entier devant la
défense comment échapper un fait qu'on
soit bien d'accord la question ici c'est
de savoir comment s'éloigner d'un pet
combien de lâcher sans qui nous suivent
histoire de laisser quelqu'un d'autre se
faire accuser à notre place dans une
vidéo japonaise filmé en caméra
thermique pour bien visualiser le nuage
de gaz chaud plusieurs techniques qui
ont été expérimentées comme celle ci par
exemple
alors c'est un document précieux hélas
hélas mille fois hélas les plus
perspicaces d'entre vous l'ont repéré il
s'agit d'une vidéo alizés humoristique
et passion dans la vraie vie on
n'échappe pas à l'inter évidemment je
vous mets quand même le lien vers la
vidéo dans la description pas ce que
vaut le détour mais de votre côté
n'hésitez pas à nous donner vos petites
techniques personnelles dans les
commentaires c'est là mais voilà
détester c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on
se retrouve très vite pour de nouvelles
vidéos d'ici là prenez soin de vous et
prenez soin des autres
mettez vous bien et surtout merci romain
portez vous bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]